[Music]
game theorists have spent a lot of time
analyzing various models of negotiation
the idea is that you take what is feels
like a complex interaction distill it
down to it's very simple elements and
then you model it using the tools of
game theory one of the things that game
theorists have found is that in
negotiation especially in negotiations
where we're debating how to divide up
some resource classic example in game
theory is dividing up a pie but it could
be anything like money
or some time with a toy or anything
where we have to decide we have to
decide how to divide it up game
theorists have discovered a couple of
central principles that make a big
difference to who does better in those
negotiations one of the critical things
is how patient you are how willing you
are to stay and continue to negotiate so
if I come in in a rush to a car
dealership and I say I need a car right
now everyone knows that the car dealer
is gonna try and take advantage of the
fact that you need a car right now and
say sorry we can't give you a discount
but if you come into a car dealership
and you say I don't need a car any time
soon if you give me a good deal today
I'll take it but if you don't I'll leave
maybe I'll come back tomorrow maybe the
next day maybe a month later then you'll
get a better a better deal so patience
is very important if you're trying to
win at a negotiation you want to try and
find ways to make it so that you are
more patients than the other person that
is you have less to lose from letting
the negotiation drag out then does the
person you're negotiating with so don't
wait till the last minute to buy a new
car don't run into the boss's office
right before you need that big raise
always choose situations where you just
suggest it saying no urgency but I can
come back later by doing that you create
the situation where the other person
can't take advantage of your impatience
they can't give you a deal that is
effectively a take-it-or-leave-it deal
another important thing in negotiation
that can lead to better outcomes for you
is you always want to be in the position
to be able to offer take-it-or-leave-it
deals to the other person so if you can
say to somebody else here's the deal
take it or leave it
now they're put in a position where they
take it where they get nothing
now it's tricky of course because I can
say to you take it or leave it but that
doesn't mean that it really is that way
so by creating situations where it
really is a take-it-or-leave-it
situation that can help you but it's
also nerve-wracking and dangerous so
it's a strategy that you have to be very
careful about but if you can if you can
be in a situation where you can offer
somebody a true take-it-or-leave-it deal
that can oftentimes improve the outcomes
of the negotiation for you
[Music]